Pope Francis refuses to answer
accusations that he knew about alleged
sex abuse by former Cardinal and allowed
him to serve unpunished while the Pope
was in Ireland in meeting sex abuse
victims a former Vatican official made
the claims in a letter this comes us in
two weeks after a scathing grand jury
report in Pennsylvania detailed sex
abuse in the Catholic Church Seth Doane
is following developments in Rome and
joins us now with the latest
Seth good morning good morning the
explosive letter was penned by the man
who was the Vatican's ambassador to the
US and he called on Pope Francis to
resign Fionan Vito una federal s request
I will not say a word about this Pope
Francis told reporters I believe the
document speaks for itself the 11 page
letter by Italian Archbishop Carlo Maria
Vigano alleges that back in 2013 he told
Pope Francis of the allegations of sex
abuse against former Cardinal Theodore
McCarrick
but he writes the pontiff ignored that
and allowed McCarrick to continue to
publicly serve the church for another
five years
the 88 year old McCarrick resigned from
his role as Cardinal earlier this summer
amid a wave of sex abuse allegations
including many involving seminarians the
letter was released in the middle of
Pope Francis's trip to Ireland
Fahim appeared on where the pontiff
asked for forgiveness in apologizing for
clerical sex abuse scandals archbishop
vegan oh now 77 makes a number of
ideological claims and is critical of
homosexuals within Church ranks he does
not offer any proof for his statements
including that Francis ignored sanctions
that had been placed on mckarrick by the
previous Pope Benedict removing him from
official church duties IRA described it
as an earthquake for the church
Monsignor with Anthony Figueredo
what is archbishop veganize reputation I
know him personally I know him as a man
of great integrity honest to the core
he's worked for three different popes
and sent to a Vatican position a
diplomatic position as big as the United
States which means
he's a trusted man CBS News has spoken
with vegan Oh to confirm that he stands
by those claims at this time two
prominent US Cardinals have disputed
some of the claims in vegan O's letter
while a man who worked with him
reportedly says they are accurate and
two US bishops have called for an
investigation Nora well there is clearly
a battle going on within the Catholic
Church at the hierarchy more on the
stories of don't roam thank you so much